today i can report to the american
people that black noir has conducted an
operation
killing the super terrorists known as
nakib
but that doesn't mean sacrifices won't
still be made
welcome back everyone it's charlie the
boys is here
diabolical this is gonna be my season
two episode one to
three video they dropped the first three
episodes i will be doing weekly episode
videos for all them so be sure to
subscribe to get everything
we're doing an amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite moment from the
episodes on the video
normally i would do top 10 wtf and
easter eggs but there's so much stuff
happening in these episodes and it's all
three episodes in this one video that
should be like top 100 wtf and it's the
boys series so it's way
crazier than most television shows
because they dropped the first three
episodes just careful for spoilers for
episodes one to three
so what i'll do is i'll number these as
we go along through the episodes and
cover all the easter eggs
but if you don't follow them on social
media they actually drop the episodes a
day early
thursday instead of friday when they
were supposed to drop as part of this
big promotional campaign
it was meant to be a joke about vaught
taking over the boy's twitter account
in the boys and butcher leaking the
episodes in retaliation
a day early the titles of the episodes
are also titles of the comic book
chapters
but the actual chapters don't
necessarily correspond to the plot of
the episodes
but it starts with the ceo of vat played
by giancarlo esposito who's a much
bigger character during season two his
name is stan
edgar so if homelander is like the evil
superman of this equation he would be
more like the lex luthor
he's negotiating with jim beaver from
supernatural who works for the
government about the terms of putting
superheroes in the military that whole
thing they were trying to set up during
season one
while black noir is busy on a hit
mission to take out the new foreign
villain homeland homelander helped
create
for the very purpose of convincing the
government in the military to let
superheroes in
all while sympathy for the devil by the
stones is playing
i guess that kind of makes giancarlo
esposito's character the quote-unquote
devil of this situation
even though you can think of black noir
as a devil of sorts i know a lot of
people are wondering how different or
how similar he's going to be to the
comic book version of his character
please don't post spoilers about black
noir in the comments because while this
hit mission is going on and he takes
down this foreign superhero he soaks a
bunch of damage revealing that he has
a whole bunch of powers that you didn't
know about but the sympathy for the
devil's song
also applies to him because this scene
where he brings the severed head and
this bunny in to freak that little kid
out in the next room
that's also a reference to comic book
black noir being the worst
worst possible person you could imagine
if you think characters on the tv show
are bad
black noir in the comics is so so much
worse
so much more wtf and if you didn't see
my video about it there's a bunch of
supernatural
characters and people that worked on the
supernatural tv show that are associated
with the boys tv show now
so i referenced jim beaver who played
bobby on supernatural
jensen ackles is actually going to be
playing soldier boy or a version of
soldier boy during season 3.
i don't know how many episodes he's
going to be in but i've already done a
video about that so i'll link it at the
end of this
but eric kripke who's the showrunner of
the boys actually used to be the
showrunner of supernatural so maybe we
get jared patalecki in a future season
too and just complete the circle
one of the big easter eggs that they
have during this conversation though
when giancarlo esposito is talking to
jim beaver
is he makes a reference to telling the
president what to do the united states
president
and that's a big arc in the comic books
vot's whole mission is that they want
more power
but in order to get real power they have
to be able to get superheroes in the
government
so superheroes in the military is a big
thing right now on the show
but the next big step as they tease here
is putting superheroes in the white
house
and i love the joke about collateral
damage 34 percent of any city that they
go to with superheroes they'll wind up
trashing so they almost cause as much
damage as they prevent
they kind of pay that off by the time we
get to episode three with kimiko's
brother
in stormfront going after both of them
when she completely trashes
an entire building just because she
feels like it
but then they transitioned to the
funeral for translucent with homelander
giving this really terrible speech
trying to continue to spin this is a big
pr move
everything that vaught does is basically
a pr move
up until this point pretty much
everything that they say everything that
they do
is all meant to just continue to feed
their big merchandising machine
sell more merch you see a couple of
jokes about that too when huey goes out
on the street walking around you just
see merch
for the seven all over the place and
then when they go to the warehouse with
all the superhero costumes
it's all vaught merch they also have
wall to wall
commercials and tv shows all trying to
pump up this narrative that they're
trying to feed to the public
about what wants them to believe they
try to pin everything on butcher and
spin him as this crazy person they're
not wrong about that
butcher is definitely crazy as they sort
of imply later in the episodes
but you can kind of see that vaut is
trying to control everything
we meet up with the deep who's still
stuck in ohio in exile from the seven
drinking his problems away getting
kicked out of some tgi friday's looking
bar
his arc is kind of hilarious in a very
sad way like as he sorely spirals out of
control into that water park
the funny thing about his arc with the
cults because he totally falls for it he
totally eats up
everything that they feed him is that
it's meant to be a parallel for huey's
ark because he's also spiraling out of
control he keeps watching that billy
joel music video they actually included
it at the beginning of episode three i
think
for the deep it winds up being the cult
that he runs to but like huey says
when we get to episode three he talks
about starlight being his quote-unquote
second wind like the billy joel song
they set up the whole compound v arc
trying to expose vot
i know a lot of people heard that
compound v and they're wondering if
they're gonna do that big huey comic
book twist
because he keeps talking about being
this normal guy i'm just a normal guy
that nobody thinks is special but he
makes all these pop culture references
like i could be the harry potter of this
group
i don't want to talk too much about that
in case it winds up being spoilers later
this season
there's a big twist with huey's
character in the comics that you can go
read if you want to right now
but they might wind up doing that for
his character by the end of this season
the mission that the boys send her on
though is part of this to get her former
squad mate to turn and help her with a
compound beat is actually right out of
the comics too she used to be part of a
super
religious themed group called the young
americans drummer boy in the comics is
the person she used to go out with
this person is called gekko so it's just
a minor change from the comics but i
think that was all in service of this
big wtf twist so they could have this
scene of him
getting paid to let people hack limbs
off he even says he'll let him chop his
junk off if he gives him an extra
thousand bucks
i also love this hilarious look on
starlight's face like this is gross but
it's not the worst thing she's seen
in the last year they said the whole
cult arc with the deep's character
getting bailed out of jail by eagle
who's obviously a big parody of hawkeye
in the avengers there are a lot of
marvel avengers easter eggs throughout
the series and during season two
the seven are just a justice league
parody and homelanders meant to be evil
superman
but there are a lot of other marvel
based character parodies in the show
but he's part of the church of the
collective either willingly or
unwillingly maybe he's been brainwashed
too it's hard to tell how much he
believes what's going on
but they set up the big fresca running
joke so anytime
a cult member walks in and introduces
themselves they keep trying to give you
fresca so fair warning if anybody in
real life offers you a fresca you turn
and you run the opposite way
i don't know which writer it was on the
show who declared war on fresca but it's
absolutely hilarious
when they go back to the boys they make
a reference on the tv about stillwell's
baby surviving and being found 17 miles
away
so i guess homelander really did save
the baby and just dropped it off while
he was taking butcher to his wife's
house
it is so weird and gross watching him
drink that tip milk the way he does he's
so obsessed with it he drinks milk so
weird on the show so many different
times that you just have to laugh out
loud
they have a big joke about ashley kind
of catching him doing it too i think she
definitely saw him drinking that tip
milk
they have another big marvel easter egg
with this daredevil parody character
homelander just completely turns on a
dime too just slapping his ears
i love how anthony starr is so good at
that too like he seems like he's kind of
going along with things congratulating
him
giving him the usual spiel he would do
in front of cameras
then completely gives her the business
about being the one in charge you're
gonna inform me on everything that's
going on
inside corporate and i'm gonna do
whatever i wanna do
that doesn't really last very long too
you can see by the end of episode three
homelander is just ready to just
completely blow a party at the seams
because he feels like he's completely
lost control of the situation
there's also a lot of references during
episode one to this tech night movie
that's getting ready to come out he's
basically a version of batman and iron
man if you're not a big comic book
reader he's a superhero that has a ton
of money but no real super powers
other than the technology that he uses
to fight crime he also has a big bat
cave too
we meet more members of the church of
the collective as the deep slowly kind
of gets sucked in
through all the fresca they make him
trip balls and he starts
talking to his gills which are voiced by
patton oswalt
when they announced that he was going to
be a character on the show i thought
that he was actually going to be a real
character
but this is way crazier than i ever
expected
then they introduced stormfront for the
first time played by aya cash
most of you might recognize her from
some other tv shows she does a lot of
comedy stuff
she's meant to be a character that's
just as bad if not worse than homelander
but in the first three episodes she's a
bit of a slow burn like they're slowly
easing you
into how crazy she really is until the
end of episode three
the whole thing with her is that she's
actually almost as powerful as
homelander so she's meant to be this
check and balance that oscar puts on the
team
as a strategic move to sort of
neutralize homelander
but even though homelander seems like he
hates her at the beginning of the season
and for most of the episodes like the
end of episode three
it seems like he's getting ready to
stare a hole right through her like he
wants to laser the crap
out of her aya cash said that she slowly
wins him over over the course of the
season once she reveals what's really
going on and if you've seen the trailer
like the scene of him
lasering her chest and her enjoying it
than them getting it on
obviously that was not in the first
three episodes so it sounds like they'll
have that confrontation pretty soon
but everyone press f in the chat for
that deputy director the cia
from season one the one that had been
together with butcher for a while
helping him out
they don't fully explain why her head
blew up only that vaught has
tabs on pretty much everybody in a
position of power
just trying to keep the lid on compound
v and the reason why she died is because
she got too close to the secret but the
secret gets out by episode 3 anyway
that they have a big standoff with
homelander and the ceo sort of telling
him what the business is
and giving us a big history lesson about
the company vought
they change a couple minor things about
the comics but for the most part it's a
pretty accurate backstory
it all started in world war ii germany
then through operation paper clip
the company and then compound v came to
the united states
where they founded vaude american
butcher comes back finally daddy's home
and explains
to the rest of the boys that his wife is
still alive and what his real plan is
there's going to be a short movie that
will cover the events between season 1
and season 2 about what butcher was up
to during that missing period i think
that's going to drop
after the finale of season 2 drops they
finally reveal
where she is when she drops her son off
for piano lessons and then races back
and we find out that vos been keeping
her in this giant jurassic park looking
facility with a huge
fence around it and i love the
conversation that she has with the
doctor
about what they're gonna do about
homelander now that he knows the secret
i don't think there's anything we can do
about it we're just kind of hoping that
he'll get tired and move on
later they remind you just how powerful
homelander is when he tells her about
that conversation letting you know that
he heard
every word even though he was a couple
miles away homelander also kind of gets
real with his son for a moment too like
he tells him the truth you know i kind
of lied to you earlier i didn't really
have a mom or a dad i didn't grow up
with that many friends
there were like a couple brief moments
during the episodes where you see him
with his son
actually enjoying himself because he so
badly wants a family but he doesn't know
how to do that he doesn't know how to be
human
in anthony starr the actor actually says
that homelanders real kryptonite
quote-unquoted for making superman
references is actually his humanity
because he wants to be a father to his
son the father that he never had
but through his actions he almost winds
up burning that bridge
because his son's powers finally
activate when he threatens butcher's
wife get away from us i hate you i don't
want to be anything like you
that's big because there are only a
couple people on the planet that are
almost powerful enough to challenge
homelander and his son
would be one of those people stormfront
is almost as powerful as homelander but
she's a little bit
better at spinning pr which is why she
seems like she's more in control of some
of these situations
which also pisses homelander off even
more they said at the whole arc with
kimiko's brother he basically got the
same compound v
treatments from the same group that
kimiko did it's just that she was
rescued by the boys and he was not so
he's still working for them
they have a series of conversations
about what happened to them after they
left their village they basically
explained that homelander destroyed
everyone there so there's no way that
they could ever go back even if they
wanted to
but also he feels all this remorse for
not being able to protect her because
he's supposed to be her brother
he tells that story about how he took
the blame for her when she was about to
get caught for stealing they broke his
hands
which they pay off at the end of episode
three when he comes back to rescue her
from stormfront but she breaks his hands
and then kills him
there's this whole butcher versus huey
thing going on in the first couple of
episodes too where huey just doesn't
want to have anything to do with butcher
and
butcher basically tells them if you get
in my way between me and my wife this
plan
i'll kill you and he is not joking the
show is not subtle about it at all but
they want to parallel
butcher in homelander they're both meant
to be psychopaths
for the most part in their own way it's
just a question of whether or not either
will find any kind of redemption
but by the end of episode 3 starlight's
plan to leak the news about compound v
is out the world knows about it but
giancarlo esposito's character winds up
pinning the whole thing on stillwell
because she can't say anything about it
because she's dead now he also kind of
pins vogelbaum on it like a small rogue
group
inside our company the speech that he
gave to homeland earlier in the season
is actually really good it explains
their business really well we are a
pharmaceutical company and our power
is really that no one knows the secret
of superheroes that we
make them there are no superheroes that
are born naturally homelander's son
is one of the first big experiments in
that because he was born naturally he
does have powers so now they know that
it's at least
possible for superheroes to be born one
of the funnier things though about that
compound v
reveal is that some of the members of
the seven only learned about it for the
first time
from the news they didn't know that they
were created as superheroes they thought
that they'd been born that way
it was the deep that talked about
learning about his powers for the first
time when he was a young child
walking through the mall listening to
all the goldfish screaming
then you see black noir crying in the
hallway or at least looks like he's
crying underneath his mask
there are a couple really funny black
noir background scenes too so he's all
over the spectrum
there were a couple other big cameos
like pj burn you probably recognized him
from a couple of the tv shows
this is really just the beginning and
obviously there's a lot of stuff that i
didn't include in this video just
because there's
so much that we could talk about from
each episode so my episode 4 video will
post next friday but if you spotted any
big easter eggs that i didn't include in
the video just write them below in the
comments like i said there's a billion
things that they referenced during these
what i'll do is i'll talk more about
some of the new characters when we get
to more of the single episode videos
like stormfront
there's a bunch of stuff going on with
stormfront that we could talk about
will you wait for everything click here
for the brand new star wars the
mandalorian season 2
teaser trailer and click here for that
boys jensen ackles
teaser video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe i'll see you
guys tonight